es gibt da ein starkes indiz dafür dass
wir in einer simulation leben das wir
nicht wirklich existieren sondern in
einem computer erschaffen wurden das hat
ein forschungsteam aus kanada jetzt
analysiert sie sind dabei so weit
gegangen wie noch niemand sofort und
damit dem rätsel auf die spur gekommen
warum wir bisher noch keine
außerirdischen gefunden haben kriegs um
zwei bis dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los ganz herzlich
willkommen pixum hat sich ja inzwischen
auch als podcast etabliert und es gibt
so viele möglichkeiten ihn zu hören wie
ihr unter dem uhr video geschrieben habt
und welcher vorschlag gewonnen hat das
erfahrt ihr am ende des videos und auch
heute habe ich einige infos zusätzlich
im podcast zum thema simulation da haben
wir schon öfter darüber berichtet und
auch in meinem buch darauf zu den
weltraum spielt das thema eine rolle ich
würde mal sagen abonnieren und anderen
klickt auf die links spotify und apple
podcast in der video beschreibung eben
angebunden kommentar oder hier unten
ganz vorne mit dabei ist tesla und space
ex-chef viele maß er ist ein großer
anhänger der sogenannten simulations-
theorie mass ist fest davon überzeugt
dass wir menschen in einer
computersimulation leben davon aber eben
gar nichts wissen seiner meinung nach
ist die chance dass wir tatsächlich real
sind minimal auf einer konferenz
bezifferte er diese auf eins zu einer
milliarde forschungsteams weltweit gehen
dieser frage nach leben wir tatsächlich
in einer simulation ohne das zu bemerken
wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dafür
und wäre das technisch überhaupt machbar
genau diesen fragen ist jetzt ein
kanadisches forschungsteam auf den grund
gegangen und die ergebnisse sind mega
spannend denn den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern ist es nicht nur
gelungen ganz konkret die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür zu berechnen
dass wir in einer virtuellen welt leben
auch in bezug auf unsere bislang
erfolglose suche nach außerirdischen
lebewesen gibt die neue studie spannende
hinweise diese frage ist nicht neu schon
der französische philosoph rené
descartes
sich im siebzehnten jahrhundert die
frage gestellt ob es die dinge die wir
mit unseren augen ohren und der nase
wahrnehmen wirklich gibt und was ist
eigentlich diese wirklichkeit leben wir
in einer art raum ein philosophisches
gedankenexperiment dazu kommt von dem
oxford wissenschaftler nick post schon
vor knapp 20 jahren hat er in seinem
aufsatz ajo living in der
computersimulation für aufregung gesorgt
laut seiner sogenannten simulations-
hypothese leben wir derzeit
wahrscheinlich in einer
computersimulation nick posthum zufolge
ist es unvermeidlich dass eine
fortgeschrittene zivilisation simulierte
welten erschafft eine davon könnten also
wir seien die große frage was passiert
mit der menschheit in vielen tausend
jahren
wie können wir uns dann unser universum
vorstellen möglich ist es dass wir
menschen bis dahin ausgestorben sind
falls wir bis dahin nicht ausgestorben
sind könnte sich aber eine posthume
spezies entwickelt haben diese könnte
technisch in der lage sein ihre
vorfahren zu simulieren und das
inklusive bewusstsein
möglicherweise sind es wirklich ethische
und moralische bedenken diese sand davon
abhalten solche programme abzuspielen
möglicherweise aber spielen sie diese
doch ab und genau an dieser stelle sind
wir bei der simulation theorie von nick
posthum die frage ist nur welches der
szenarien eintrifft und welche rolle wir
einnehmen
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist nach ansicht
des wissenschaftlers jedenfalls sehr
gering dass wir die echte zivilisation
sind der es gelingen wird die
notwendigen supercomputer zu entwickeln
um unsere vorfahren zu simulieren der
grund laut post raum kann es eben nur
eine echte welt geben von den
simulierten welten dagegen können
aufgrund der enormen rechenleistung der
supercomputer viele nebeneinander
existieren die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
laut post vom also riesig dass wir eben
in einer dieser virtuellen welten leben
er selbst geht von einer
wahrscheinlichkeit von etwa 20 prozent
aus edel maas dagegen schätzt sie wie
eben angedeutet auf volle 100 und es
gibt weitere bekannte anhänger dieser
simulations- theorie beispielsweise in
der computer experte george hotz der
bereits im alter von 17 jahren das
iphone gehackt hatte er hatte es mal als
sein lebensziel erklärt aus dieser
seiner meinung nach computer generiert
welt zu finden ein forschungsteam aus
kanada hat sich jetzt genauer mit diesen
fragen beschäftigt den forschenden ging
es vor allem darum ob ein leben in einer
simulation technisch überhaupt machbar
ist eine weitere entscheidende frage die
die beiden wissenschaftler alexander
bode lille und will basar von der
universität montreal in ihrer studie
beantworten wollten wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit für einen simulierten
kosmos dazu gab es bereits in der
vergangenheit einige analysen doch die
kanadischen fachleute wählten einen
anderen ansatz mit hilfe eines
mathematischen modells überprüften sie
auch die möglichkeit dass die
denkprozesse von uns menschen so wie
unsere interaktion mit der umwelt über
technische lösung simuliert werden
können infrage dafür kommen
quantencomputer und kranken operationen
das forschungsteam wollte auch
herausfinden ob simulierte wesen auch
selbst simulationen durchführen könnten
und welche energie aufwand dafür
notwendig wären in ihrer analyse
stellten die beiden forscher schnell
fest dass ein gigantischer rechenaufwand
benötigt würde
falls wir uns also tatsächlich in einer
virtuellen welt bewegen müssten
unvorstellbare mengen an rechenleistung
vorhanden sein um diese simulation zu
ermöglichen und am laufen zu halten
dabei wurde das autorenteam in seinen
berechnungen auch ziemlich konkret und
stellte sich der frage wie viel
rechenleistung notwendig wäre um allein
die leistung der menschlichen gehirne zu
simulieren
demnach wird nämlich ein
durchschnittliches menschliches gehirn
mit einer masse von 1,4 kilogramm
zwischen 10 14 und 10 hoch 16
operationen pro sekunde aus
zivilisationen mit der entsprechenden
technologie könnten also pro sekunde und
kilogramm etwa zehn hoch 50 operationen
ausführen und weiter geht es in der
analyse
eine zivilisation müsste demnach in der
lage sein mindestens einen milliardsten
teil der energie die in materie
gespeichert ist in rechenleistung
umzuwandeln
unter dieser voraussetzung könnte diese
zivilisation mit nur einem computer von
der masse eines gehirns die entwicklung
von 1,4 mal 10 hoch 25 virtuellen gehirn
simulieren doch fest steht einzig und
allein die simulation von intelligenten
wesen würde nicht ausreichen als zweiter
step müsste solch eine situation auch
die interaktion mit der umwelt erfassen
und nicht nur das auch naturgesetze
würden hier eine rolle spielen dazu
schreibt das autorenteam in der
aktuellen studie
wenn sie nur welten app sollten wollen
in denen intelligente wesen leben und
interagieren wäre es vorteilhaft
naturgesetze zu wählen die zwar
intelligenz zu lassen aber die kosten
für eine simulation der umwelt
minimieren heißt also im klartext eine
virtuelle simulation mit naturgesetzen
physikalischen gesetzen die der realität
entsprechen wäre enorm aufwendig den
berechnungen des kanadischen
forschungsteams zufolge würde dafür
nicht einmal eine maximale rechen dichte
ausreichend zitat es wäre extrem
aufwändig diese umwelt dann bis in das
kleinste mikroskopische niveau zu
simulieren denkbar wäre es demnach aber
dass die simulation in ihrer komplexität
variable gestaltet sind möglicherweise
wäre die weiter entwickelte zivilisation
in der lage die auflösung der simulation
zu erhöhen wenn dies gerade gefragt wäre
beispielsweise wenn menschen gerade
astronomische erkundung durchführen oder
aber experimente in der quantenphysik
durchführt wenn das augenmerk der
menschen dann wieder bei anderen dingen
liegt könnte diese komplexität der
simulation wieder runtergefahren werden
doch was aber passiert wenn dann
wiederum die simulierten wesen damit
beginnen zu simulieren und dabei
computer nutzen für die computer auf der
realen ebene würden die benötigten
rechenkapazitäten in die höhe schießen
denn sie müssen ja dann nicht nur die
simulation auf der ersten ebene am
laufen halten sondern eben auch die
simulation der simulierten zivilisation
dazu schreibt das autorenteam noch
dramatischer wird es wenn die simulierte
zivilisation große mengen
rechenkapazität auf für verschiedene
andere zwecke nutzt zusätzlich zu ihren
eigenen simulationen in der fachsprache
ist hier von re kursiven simulationen
die rede
die rechenkapazitäten auf der realen
ebene würden dann höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht mehr ausreichen
und so kommen die beiden wissenschaftler
zudem gesamtfazit dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir in einer
simulierten welt lebens bei zitat weit
unter 50 prozent liegt das hauptargument
für dieses ergebnis lautet die
hauptfaktoren für diese geringe
wahrscheinlichkeit sind der enorme
aufwand um die umwelt einer zivilisation
überzeugung zu simulieren
die unvermeidlichen perfekte effizienz
jeder computer operation und die
tatsache
das simulation re kursiv sein können ein
fakt jedoch ist verdächtig und spricht
eindeutig dafür dass unser leben eine
simulation ist unsere bisher erfolglose
suche nach außerirdischem leben
denn würden wir tatsächlich in einer
virtuellen welt leben würde diese suche
wohl immer erfolglos bleiben denn die
macher der simulierten erde würden sich
ganz sicher den aufwand sparen in großer
entfernung zur erde
weitere wesen zu simulieren dazu heißt
es in der aktuellen studie
wenn wir in einer simulation mit
vereinfachter für sich leben werden wir
solchen sollten niemals begegnen dass
wir bisher keine hinweise auf
extraterrestrische zivilisationen
delektiert haben könnte daher als
überzeugendes argument für die
simulation theorie gewertet werden ja
und mehr infos zum thema gibt es hier
auf die ohren im podcast also anklicken
anhören und abonnieren
und die originellste antwort wo man den
podcast am besten hören kann hatte
frederik salomo er sagt dass er den
podcast im cern in genf hört während er
kristalle schleift erst dachten wir das
ist kreativ ausgedacht aber das ist kein
scherz das macht er wirklich erarbeitet
am cern und klicks um hört er
tatsächlich beim kristall schleifen
das finden wir natürlich mega und
deshalb geht der name
experimentierkasten an ihn
herzlichen glückwunsch und hier gehts
zum podcast also anklicken anhören und
abonnieren und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran